[Musique]
étranger
compagnon [
Musique]
est
[Musique]
cancer
dans lequel nous gardions les enfants la nuit nous ne
laissions pas sortir six à sept pieds de haut de
couleur grise une grande envergure de 10 à 12 pieds
envergure sept pieds de haut avec l'
envergure de 50 pieds avec
des yeux rouges brillants six pieds de haut avec les grandes ailes
et les yeux rouges parce que tout le monde dit qu'il
y a des yeux rouges comme vous ne pouvez pas manquer
ce détail ces yeux c'est ce
que les cheveux ont fait était-ce un rouge  beaucoup de
gens disent que ça brillait je ne sais pas à ce sujet
je sais juste que c'était un rouge comme
vous n'en avez jamais vu rouge
euh une personne a pensé que c'était un
hélicoptère c'était si gros
un autre gars du coin ici il a pensé que c'était
un avion
d'autres personnes l'ont décrit comme ressemblant à
un papillon de nuit géant parce qu'il n'avait pas
de tête comme un humain, il était plus à l'intérieur et
il avait des ailes de papillon de nuit et ainsi de suite
d'autres personnes l'ont décrit comme euh vous savez
être très rapide jusqu'au vol  tu
sais que ça apparaîtrait et puis
ça disparaîtrait
mon papa a toujours dit que ce n'était qu'un oiseau
parce qu'il avait l'habitude d'aller là-bas tout le
temps mais il a dit qu'il avait vu quelque chose
là-bas alors je vais le croire
le  colline comme nous le faisons un talon et un long
pied avec des orteils en griffe et des griffes au
bout des orteils il avait un cou comme nous
qui tient une tête de type rond il avait un
nez comme nous et j'ai vu deux trous que
vous respirez  sur
multiplier
Well Point Pleasant tel qu'il est aujourd'hui est un endroit
très simple c'est un endroit simple
et dans les années 60 c'était encore plus si
vous aviez des agriculteurs américains qui travaillent dur
et des gens comme ça ça ne faisait vraiment pas le
point sur les monstres  ou des OVNIS ou
quelque chose comme ça, ils ont travaillé de longues journées
et des journées difficiles et ils étaient des
gens pratiques qui allaient à
l'église le dimanche ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
quelque chose qu'ils ont comploté ou planifié
c'est juste quelque chose qui s'est passé et
ils pouvaient '  Je ne l'explique
même pas aujourd'hui, toutes ces années plus tard, c'est
toujours un mystère. Certains de ces
témoins Mothman euh euh vous savez sont devenus
très
vous savez qu'ils ont souffert de
dépressions nerveuses et de problèmes mentaux et
des choses et des gens totalement différents quant à ce
qu'ils étaient auparavant
au fil des ans  vous savez qu'ils
n'ont jamais pu trouver une réponse viable
à ce qui s'est passé ou à ce qu'ils ont
vécu
beaucoup de gens dans la ville ont reçu
des messages de pensée alors ils ont dit euh disant
que quelque chose allait se passer certaines
personnes avaient même des effets physiques
comme leurs yeux gonflés et
rouges et ainsi de suite sans
raison particulière en fait, je pense que beaucoup de gens
ont eu des rencontres rapprochées avec cette
créature Mothman euh dit que leurs yeux se sont
enflammés et qu'avez-vous, cela aurait pu
être comme un ange de  la mort ou un présage
comme la personnification d'un présage la
venue de personnes chaleureuses que quelque chose de
terrible allait se produire
point agréable
quand le pont est tombé il s'est en fait incliné
vers la droite est remonté puis est juste
descendu c'est au lieu d'un effondrement
comme parfois  nous voyons à la télévision ou sur
des images les témoins oculaires ont dit qu'il est
en fait allé sur le côté puis est
remonté et est descendu
[Musique]
étranger
il y avait deux jeunes couples près de la
centrale électrique nord dans le  Zone TNT qui
était une zone désolée évacuée à un moment donné
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale qui était une
usine de munitions, c'est ainsi que cela nous a fait
nommer la zone TNT qu'ils conduisaient là-
haut vers 11 heures du
soir, ils sont tombés sur ce qu'ils pensaient
être un  homme debout sur la route
devant leur voiture, ils ont remarqué quelque chose
debout à côté de la plante
qui ressemblait à un très grand homme vêtu de
vêtements sombres ou d'un manteau et qu'avez-
vous et ils ont remarqué ces deux
yeux rouges éblouissants et la scarberry était l'un
des  des témoins ont dit qu'ils étaient à peu près de la
taille de balles de baseball à environ deux pouces l'un de l'autre,
puis elle a remarqué que des ailes battaient
sur son dos et elle a dit qu'elles
lui rappelaient les ailes d'Angel Angel alors que
la voiture se rapprochait, elle a dit que les ailes
sont sorties
et cette créature ou être ou  tout ce qui
s'est heurté à l'un des bâtiments vacants de la centrale électrique
là-bas appelé la
centrale électrique nord
et a en quelque sorte effrayé les dames
et elles ont pris de la vitesse et elles ont
remarqué en regardant derrière elles euh
que cette chose les poursuivait en fait
c'est là que cette chose est arrivée
en haut de leur voiture, ils faisaient 90 à 95
miles à l'heure dans cette voiture qui revenait
en ville et par intermittence, cette
chose passait au-dessus de la voiture puis
disparaissait, venait au-dessus de la voiture et elle
les chassait dans les limites de la ville
, puis elle a disparu et  ils étaient
complètement terrifiés mais ils sont rentrés à la maison
euh et ont raconté leur histoire et pendant ce
temps, cela a commencé le bal sur
toute la légende de Mothman car c'est l'une des
légendes urbaines les plus effrayantes d'Amérique
immédiatement après que les deux couples ont
vu cette chose chez les adolescents ici ils
sont allés au département du shérif maintenant l'
adjoint du shérif a vu à quel point ils étaient bouleversés,
ils savaient qu'ils
n'inventaient pas cette histoire, ils se sont
assis et ont écrit tout ce qu'ils
ont rencontré, puis la police est montée
là-bas pour enquêter,
ils ont commencé à courir  des patrouilles régulières
c'était le 15 novembre le
16 novembre euh Marcella Bennett sa
famille a rencontré cette chose
dans une maison dans la région de TNT
j'ai demandé à ma sœur à quoi ça ressemblait
un jour j'ai dit Marcel je dois te demander
quoi  est-ce que ça ressemble vraiment parce que j'étais
là à maintes reprises mais que je n'ai jamais
vraiment pu en faire l'expérience
et elle a dit que vous savez ce que Carolyn a
dit, nous sortions juste de la voiture,
nous parlions d'avant en arrière au-dessus
de la voiture sans payer un  beaucoup d'attention
sans penser à rien et j'ai entendu
quelque chose comme
et elle a dit que nous nous sommes retournés et avons regardé
et il essayait de franchir les
portes qu'ils ont conduit des camions et des chars
et des trucs à travers les portes et ont dit
qu'ils n'étaient pas les portes était  't
assez grand et j'ai dit bien alors comment est-il
sorti et elle a dit qu'il est allé de côté
et est passé et a volé au-dessus de
lui, elle a dit quand j'ai levé les yeux et vu
les grands yeux rouges, il a dit que nous étions
là-bas, je peux '  Je ne vous dirai pas à quoi
ressemblent les autres, vous pouvez continuer
jusqu'en novembre, vous savez qu'il y a eu
toutes sortes d'observations après cela, puis
le service de police a commencé à prendre un
peu plus au sérieux
le nom Mothman qui a été donné par un
journaliste pendant  certaines de ces
conférences de presse au début des
observations de Mothman, je demande toujours
bien comment cela a-t-il pu arriver au nom de Mothman
à l'époque au milieu des années 60 alors que j'étais
un petit enfant, je regardais la
série télévisée Batman qui était aussi le  Dans la
série de bandes dessinées Batman, il y avait un personnage
dans cette série de bandes dessinées appelée Mothman
et parce que les gens décrivaient des papillons de nuit
comme des ailes et des yeux rouges, ce nom
Mothman est resté maintenant, beaucoup de gens de la région
l'appellent encore à ce jour le grand
oiseau chaque fois que le Mothman  a été repéré pour la première fois,
il couvrait pratiquement tous
nos domaines d'actualités, c'était dans les
gros articles des journaux et c'était à
la radio, à la télévision, le bouche à oreille dont
tout le monde parlait, je veux dire,
c'était différent, c'était un morceau  de
quelque chose qu'ils n'avaient jamais
vécu auparavant vous avez gardé vos enfants
la nuit votre petit vous ne les avez pas laissés
sortir le compte rendu du journal est sorti
d'un gros oiseau de six pieds avec une
grande envergure de perruque et des yeux rouges
poursuivaient des voitures dans le  Zone TNT
qui a poussé un grand
nombre de personnes à se diriger vers la
zone TNT pour voir cet oiseau massif qui
chassait des voitures.
Point Pleasant, y compris John Keel, le
regretté auteur John Keel a vraiment passé beaucoup
de temps sur tout cela, il y est resté
plusieurs mois, je crois, pendant
des années à faire des recherches pour son travail, euh,
il l'a pris comme des prémonitions et je crois
que c'était en 2002, ils sont venus  avec
le film euh bien basé sur son livre The
Mothman Prophecies
ici des choses qui se sont passées et c'était un
peu différent et les gens avaient peur
parce que vous savez que vous avez un peu peur
de ce que vous ne savez pas et ils n'ont pas
communiqué avec  eux ne savaient pas s'il
allait blesser quelqu'un il n'a blessé
personne mais il y a eu un animal tué
mais ça aurait pu être un coyote mais vous
ne saviez pas ce qui allait arriver
et les gens étaient un peu nerveux pendant
les observations de Mothman ici à Point
Pleasant, ils ne laisseraient pas certains des
enfants sortir pour la récréation parce que les
gens ne savaient pas ce qu'était cette chose,
ils pensaient que si c'était un gros oiseau, il
pourrait descendre et ramasser un petit enfant
et décoller  avec eux, c'est ainsi que
certaines personnes étaient paranoïaques quand tout cela se
passait, cela s'appelait l'oiseau
où un endroit où beaucoup de gens
les voyaient de moi et connu comme l'
oiseau était la centrale électrique du nord et il
était généralement connu sous le nom de  Le Birdhouse, je
pense qu'il a été démoli au début des années 90,
il a été considéré comme un danger pour la santé, puis
ils ont fait Dan, ce qui est un peu dommage
car ce serait comme un grand
monument que nous montons tout le temps pour le groupe de papillons
de nuit.  sais ce que nous aurions
fait pour la fondation j'aurais aimé pouvoir
dire oui c'est à quoi ça ressemble
mais tu sais que c'était quelque chose à faire et
tu es curieux et et nous y sommes allés mais nous
avions Carlos il n'allait pas  sortez
quand nous y étions Association
[Musique]
Down The Point Opérations de points agréables
Village
[Musique]
pendant toute cette période en 1966 à 67
euh
des gens signalant des lumières étranges dans le
ciel donc on a la connexion OVNI qui
fait  c'est encore plus étrange qu'il ne l'est
déjà il y
avait beaucoup d'OVNIS dans la région à
ce moment-là, est-ce que je le croyais non mais nous
serions ma sœur et j'irais
à Buffalo et nous sortirions et regarderions
et ce serait  être de belles lumières dans le ciel
et nous dirions bien que les OVNIS sont sortis
ce soir mais est-ce que je le croyais non je ne l'ai pas fait
et Un a atterri dans le jardin de mon frère
alors je l'ai cru il a dit que c'était la
chose la plus brillante qu'il ait jamais vue
et  ça ne pouvait pas, vous ne pouviez même pas le
regarder, il était si brillant et il a juste
repris et s'est envolé
comme s'il n'y avait pas de son
Mothman
I
The Point Pleasant song
[Music]
dès que les gens ont commencé à les signaler
euh
Les gens ont commencé à voir Mothman et UFO, euh, ces soi-disant
Men In Black, tout comme dans les films, vous
savez les chapeaux noirs et les lunettes de soleil et
ils intimidaient
les gens en disant de ne pas en parler, ils
ne savaient pas s'ils étaient gouvernement
agents s'ils étaient des forces de l'ordre
ou s'ils venaient d'un autre
royaume,
nous verrions les hommes en noir
debout dans la rue pendant la journée, je
veux dire si je vais à la banque et que je me change dans
la rue, ils resteraient là à
regarder  juste regarder certains de ces
témoins ont commencé à dire hé vous savez que
ces gens viennent à notre porte et
nous posent des questions et nous disent
de ne pas en parler à qui que ce soit, la
journaliste du journal local que Mary a embauchée a dit
qu'ils viendraient dans son bureau et elle
n'a pas  Je ne les connais pas, ils ne se sont pas identifiés,
mais ils ont insisté sur le fait
qu'elle ne rapportait pas
ces détails au journal et
aux médias, ce qui a commencé à inquiéter quelques
personnes car elles ne savaient pas quel était
l'agenda de ces soi-disant hommes en
noir.  avait mais ils n'étaient pas vraiment contents
que les gens discutent des ovnis ou des
observations de Mothman
[Musique]
mon frère voulait venir dans la
région de TNT pour chercher le Mothman parce que
nous en avions entendu parler ce jour-là à l'école
et nous n'étions pas  t à l'intérieur, je dirais
probablement deux trois pâtés de maisons quand mon
frère a regardé et a vu quelque chose à côté de
la voiture de mon côté de la fenêtre du conducteur,
alors mon frère a claqué sur les freins et
quand il l'a fait, la voiture a en quelque sorte tourné
de côté un peu sur la route  et
quand nous avons fait cette chose, nous nous sommes juste arrêtés et
avons sauté directement sur le capot de la voiture
et c'est comme si nous étions juste gelés
dans le temps pendant environ je ne sais pas cinq
secondes cinq minutes dix minutes je ne
sais pas bien ça a regardé à travers le
pare-brise vers nous et nous l'avons regardé à
travers le pare-brise
après son départ avec mon frère a fait
demi-tour et nous sommes allés directement au
département du shérif à Point Pleasant
on dirait qu'ils perdent l'explosif
alors nous sommes remontés à la tente ici il y
avait
deux ou trois personnes debout là-bas
sur le côté en train de parler à d'autres
militaires mais ils étaient en
costume alors l'un d'eux est venu ici vers
la voiture
il a juste mis ses mains sur le vent il a
dit qu'on vous avait dit de partir maintenant laissez-moi
[  Musique]
est
Point Pleasant
Cruise
quand une boîte de tue géante dont il parle
pourrait être en fait des
prophéties de Martin, il parle de zones de fenêtres
qui sont comme
euh des parties comme des zones de notre terre ou
certains comme divers endroits autour de la
Terre dans le globe  que euh ils
ressemblent plus à Paranormal Activity et je
pense que c'est ce que euh Point Pleasant est il
y avait plusieurs personnes, y compris John
Keo, qui recevaient des prophéties pour
des événements futurs dont certains sont venus à travers
certains locataires
euh il y avait des appels téléphoniques étranges
et  certains de ces appels impliquaient des voix
qui donnaient ces prophéties
[Musique]
le Mothman est quelque chose qui a effrayé
beaucoup de gens
Je crois personnellement qu'il y avait une telle
créature et je ne pense pas cependant que
c'était un OVNI Je ne le pense pas  était un
occupant d'une autre planète
qui est en partie le système de croyance pour
beaucoup de gens petite ville dans les années 60,
ils n'avaient pas toutes les lumières dans le
faste et la technologie, donc
ils auraient simplement apprécié ces
histoires et cela les aurait excités
et les a effrayés et la peur peut générer
toutes sortes de réponses
certaines personnes ont estimé que cela remontait il
y a des années à une malédiction indienne qui a été
infligée à la ville de Point Pleasant
par un chef indien cornstalk
ce qui s'est passé était que le chef cornstalk et
son fils étaient tous les deux  assassiné à cause d'un
différend foncier à propos de vous savez avec des colons
et l'histoire a raconté qu'à son
dernier souffle, il a maudit la ville de Point
Pleasant pendant les 200 prochaines années, certaines
personnes le croient, mais le chef
cornstalk existait bien son fils et ils ont
tous les deux été tués  maintenant, qu'il ait ou non
jeté cette malédiction sur la ville de Point
Pleasant reste un mystère,
bien sûr, tout ce qui s'est passé si nous
avions une épave, c'était soit du
stock de maïs, soit un Mothman si nous avions une
panne de courant ou principalement leur pouvoir
des pannes et des trucs comme ça, ils
ont contribué à Mothman
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne Mothman, je crois que
c'est juste quelque chose que nous n'avons pas
encore découvert ou quelque chose qui
existait et qui est peut-être mort,
c'est quelque chose de naturel c'est ce que la
ligne de fond  c'est que l'
élément surnaturel est aussi romantique et euh aussi élégant
qu'il sera très très difficile à prouver
Hommes
en noir, tout cela se passait en
même temps, apparemment, les gens
avaient des schémas de pensée comme si quelque chose
de mauvais allait arriver, quelque chose de vraiment
terrible, les gens rêvent de voir une
présence flottant dans l'eau et ainsi de
suite des rêves bizarres vraiment bizarres, mais
ils ne l'ont pas fait.  Je ne le prends pas vraiment à cœur
parce qu'ils ont
juste pensé que ce n'était qu'un rêve étrange
Décembre 1967 Le 15 décembre, le
Silver Bridge, un pont vieux de 40 ans
ici même au centre-ville de Point
Pleasant, s'est effondré un vendredi soir
aux heures de pointe a tué 46 personnes cet
événement
a attiré plus d'attention sur Point Pleasant
en plus des observations de Mothman, certaines
personnes ont estimé que c'était juste un moment très étrange
pour l'activité de Mothman dans l'
activité OVNI, ils ont estimé qu'il pouvait y
avoir eu une sorte de lien,
évidemment, c'était une terrible tragédie
le
la nous savions que la plupart des gens qui
descendaient sur le pont en fait les parents
du maire à ce moment-là étaient sur
le pont une petite fille qui était dans ma
classe était sur le pont avec
ses parents certaines personnes prétendaient avoir
vu  un grand oiseau volant dans les deux sens à
travers la rivière quelques jours avant la chute de ce pont,
d'autres personnes ont
déclaré avoir vu des hommes vêtus de
vêtements noirs monter et descendre sur ce
pont maintenant, que ces observations ou
rapports puissent être validés, c'est une autre
histoire mais les gens sont venus  en avant et dire
qu'un groupe contrôlé conscient si vous
voulez est quelque chose où un groupe de
personnes peut voir quelque chose ou une personne le
verra et ensuite une autre personne le
verra et ensuite cela descendra dans ce
groupe dans cette communauté quoi que ce soit
c'est  définitivement réel nous l'avons vu je l'ai vu
aussi alors ça devient hystérie donc dans une
petite communauté bien sûr je l'ai vu vous l'avez vu
c'est réel et ils vont s'en tenir à
cela cela devient presque une
expérience religieuse maintenant un autre aspect à cela est
le système de croyance  une fois que vous croyez en
quelque chose de si fort,
cela restera avec vous pendant des années et
des années et même quelque chose qui
ne s'est pas vraiment produit ou quelque chose qui
a été mal compris sera toujours aussi
fort 40 50 ans plus tard parce qu'ils
vont s'en souvenir  c'est exactement la façon dont
ils l'ont vécu,
ils ont vu quelque chose qui était très
effrayant pour eux et fascinant
beaucoup de ces gens n'étaient pas vraiment
ravis de le voir
ils ne l'ont pas fait certains d'entre eux ne
sortiraient même pas la nuit vous savez ils
sont devenus reclus
ils sentaient que quelque chose regardait toujours
par-dessus leur épaule ou dans leur
quartier où ils étaient très paranoïaques,
ils n'aimaient pas vraiment l'attention
qu'ils recevaient des
citadins parce que les gens pensaient qu'ils
étaient fous ou vous connaissez Looney ou
autre et c'est pourquoi  beaucoup de ces
témoins, même à ce jour, n'en
discuteront pas ils n'admettront pas que cela
ne s'est pas produit ils me diront que cela s'est
produit ils l'ont vu de leurs propres yeux
mais c'est tout ce qu'ils veulent dire
à ce sujet
ces structures sont
là depuis plus de 60 ans, elles sont
relativement intactes car vous pouvez voir tous
les détails sur celles-ci, vous pouvez réellement
marcher en dessous, vous savez, regardez en dessous
et elles sont très étranges, surtout la
nuit, surtout quand le brouillard commence à se
mettre en place  ici, ils sont fondamentalement les
mêmes qu'ils étaient de retour pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
lorsque la guerre s'est terminée, ils ont juste laissé
tout ce qu'ils n'ont jamais rien détruit
et pendant les observations de Mothman, vous
savez que beaucoup de gens pensaient que
quoi que cette chose
soit se percher ou rester  dans
cette zone générale ici dans la zone TNT
[Musique]
étrangère
[Musique] la
catastrophe
est
Opération mystérieuse,
certaines personnes disent que le Mothman a
quelque chose à voir avec la chute du pont d'argent,
ma réponse est que le pont d'argent est
tombé à cause de la fissure  Eye bar
il y avait un eye bar qui était avant
la tour de l'Ohio sur le pont, il s'est fissuré
et c'est ce qui a fait tomber le pont
maintenant la 13e broche assez étrangement
qui maintenait le pont ensemble
et scientifiquement parlant notre
ingénierie du point de vue d'un ingénieur
quand ils ont fait des tests sur le pont
après l'accident après son effondrement,
ils ont dit qu'il n'était pas étonnant qu'il
ne se soit pas effondré plus tôt, c'était le vieux
pont, il était obsolète, il devait
changer c'est une question de dossier
le fait que c'était  la 13e épingle qui a
été ajoutée, vous connaissez un autre
élément surnaturel et c'est génial pour la
légende urbaine qu'il ajoute, cela le rend
attaché au mystère, il
y a d'autres personnes qui disent que le
Mothman était une sorte de présage de la
chute du pont  Je ne sais pas où ils ont
eu cette idée
bien dans les années 60, ils avaient très mal un très
mauvais ou c'était juste une négligence
dans leur élimination de certains des
sous-produits de cette usine de TNT,
donc il est entré dans l'aquifère l'aquifère
est l'eau principale  source et ils
l'auraient utilisé et même s'ils avaient peut-être
eu des processus de purification qui, j'en suis
sûr, éliminent beaucoup de
polluants et de cancérigènes et qu'en pensez-
vous, certains d'entre eux peuvent avoir traversé
et avoir causé un effet hallucinogène
[  Musique]
si possible si le sol était saturé
d'une sorte de polluant inconnu qui
provoquait un effet hallucinogène et que vous
voyiez une vraie
créature cryptide cryptozoologique, vous
allez commencer à voir toutes sortes de
choses différentes
et ce qui ressemblait à ce qui allait être
totalement naturel  à un biologiste ou à un
ornithologue ou quelque chose comme ça
même avec leur étonnement envers des gens comme
vous et les mèmes jamais vus ces choses
avant ça va être effrayant
je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de choses que je
ne comprends tout simplement pas et avec ça je
le prends  avec un grain de sel mais je ne discrédite pas ce
que les gens disent qu'ils voient, c'est
ce que je pense que c'est je pense euh ça
appartient la créature elle-même appartient au
domaine de la cryptozoologie je pense que euh
crypto signifie que c'est quelque chose de différent
quelque chose de déplacé qui n'est pas naturel à
trouver et de temps en temps la nature
crache quelque chose qui ne devrait pas être
là
et je pense que c'est un de ces cas, il y
avait eu euh plusieurs descriptions de témoins oculaires
et des récits de certaines de ces
observations de Mothman qui pointaient vers  la
possibilité qu'il s'agisse peut-être d'un
Thunderbird ou d'un oiseau préhistorique, j'avais
en fait parlé à une dame qui l'avait vu
à la lumière du jour dans la région de TNT et elle
l'a décrit comme un oiseau préhistorique. Certaines
personnes ont estimé que le Mothman
était peut-être un Thunderbird ou
quelque chose d'éteint c'est comme n'importe quel autre
monstre de type crypto comme la
légende Bigfoot ou dans l'État de Floride Skunk
Ape ou quelque chose comme ça beaucoup de gens
disent oui existe absolument nous l'avons vu
nous ne savons pas ce que c'est pourquoi n'attrapons-nous pas
ces choses que vous penseriez qu'elles
laisseraient une sorte de preuve euh vous
savez bien qu'en est-il d'un corps que vous connaissez les
anthropologues et les archéologues ils
ont besoin de ces choses des données empiriques pour
y croire et sans cela ça
va rester dans le domaine du folklore
ou  ou mythe
Radioactif
J'aurais aimé qu'il y ait beaucoup plus de
créatures surnaturelles cela rendrait
la vie plus intéressante
mais je pense que dans ce cas c'était juste
quelque chose qui existait euh existe
toujours et qui sortait de temps en temps de là
il aurait pu être muté il aurait pu
être muté  par cette zone particulière
où les terrains sont empoisonnés, ils le
sont encore à ce jour, l'EPA
essaie de nettoyer cela parfois euh
comme si vous vous souvenez des vieux films de monstres d'abeilles,
vous savez qu'ils ont reçu des radiations ou que
quelque chose devient organique et qu'avez-vous
dedans  dans la plupart des cas, les radiations tuent purement
et simplement, mais de temps en temps, elles
modifient l'ADN, elles modifient les schémas de croissance, etc., les
plantes et les personnes que vous
connaissez après la Seconde Guerre mondiale, vous pouvez trouver
toutes sortes d'effets différents des
radiations pour ceux qui ont survécu.  des
effets effrayants qui donnent aux humains un
aspect non humain,
donc cela pourrait aussi arriver dans la nature et je
pense que c'est aussi
une possibilité crédible
[Musique]
Je pense qu'après l'effondrement du Silver Bridge,
toute la ville était dans l'
état de choc, je veux dire qu'ils n'ont jamais vu un
catastrophe, vous savez à cette échelle, vous
savez, 46 personnes que vous connaissez ont péri dans
une catastrophe de pont, c'était la
pire catastrophe de pont au monde de
l'histoire américaine, mais je pense que
vous le savez, il se passait tellement de choses que
les gens avaient du mal  absorbant toute
l'activité et l'attention, mais
vous connaissez des gens, vous savez que nous sommes dans
le domaine de la TNT, vous savez des années et des années,
même à ce jour, il est vraiment
difficile de dire que ce livre
sera un jour fermé, vous savez ce que c'est
Mothman ou grand oiseau était en fait
toute la beauté des
histoires de Mothman, les gens
recherchent toujours des réponses
étrangères
[La musique]
sera probablement toujours là
Je pense que l'idée de cette créature sera
toujours là, cela peut en effet être
quelque chose des Royaumes de  terminez
Supernatural et ils nous époustouflent
Un jour en se présentant peut-être que c'est
une vie extraterrestre Je ne peux pas ignorer que mon
système de croyance personnel est que c'est juste
une mauvaise identification,
c'est une belle histoire mais je pense que s'il y a
20 ans, quelqu'un serait venu
en avant et dit c'est ce que c'était
voici la preuve voici le
livre de documentation fermé vous savez que nous
ne serions pas assis ici en ce moment
nous ne savons tout simplement pas jusqu'à ce qu'il meure dans les
bois et que le département des forêts le
récupère et il devient des nouvelles et  ça va dans
les manuels scolaires en classe ça va
rester le monstre que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
[La musique]
est la célébrité
le film a changé les choses en nous mettant là-
bas en mettant Point Pleasant sur la
carte c'était une grande partie de la
partie climatique du  le film est le pont qui tombe
alors maintenant tout le monde veut vous poser des questions sur
le Mothman et partout où vous voyagez
si vous êtes de Point Pleasant toujours la
première chose que quelqu'un vous demande est
le Mothman
mais les gens ont eu du mal à voir ce
film en ville
euh, c'est difficile de regarder ce pont tomber
et c'est difficile de regarder les Mothman
Parts à ce sujet
quand ce film est sorti, les vannes viennent
de s'ouvrir et vous savez que la ville
était juste envahie, vous savez que les gens viennent
ici, vous savez qu'ils voulaient aller là où
le  euh, vous savez que cela s'est réellement produit,
je savais à ce moment-là que cela
changerait la ville,
mais vous savez, euh, que vous croyiez
au Mothman ou non,
cela a beaucoup fait pour Point Pleasant
[Music]
Mothman Festival est le plus grand
attracteur
de tout le  pays dans le monde
que nous avons ici à Point Pleasant,
vous ne pouvez pas conduire sur la rue principale car
elle est pleine de gens
et ils viennent de partout dans le monde,
nous avons eu des gens de Chine, d'Australie,
du Japon, d'Angleterre, ils viennent de partout où
ils viennent  dans ce Mothman Festival après la
sortie du film The Mothman Prophecies
Jeff et Carolyn Harris ont eu
l'idée que nous devrions avoir un festival
chaque année pour amener toutes les personnes qui
seraient intéressées par quelque chose comme
ça
Je parlais à Carolyn un jour et  J'ai dit que
vous savez que nous devrions peut-être essayer un
festival Mothman ou une convention
quelque chose comme ça, c'était en
novembre 2002. C'était quelques mois seulement
après la sortie du film et nous avons décidé d'
essayer, nous avons décidé comme en
octobre de cela  un an pour l'avoir, donc nous
n'avions qu'un mois, nous n'avons pas fait de publicité,
nous ne l'avons pas vraiment diffusé dans
les médias, mais nous avons eu quatre ou 500
personnes qui se sont présentées de bouche à oreille et
c'était le catalyseur  pour ce qui est maintenant
la 12e année du festival Mothman
et nous avons des conférenciers au State
Theatre, nous avons des divertissements sur le
parc au bord de la rivière et parfois nous avons des
concours de karaoké, nous avons eu un
concours d'haltérophilie là-bas
euh nous avons beaucoup de vendeurs ici un
beaucoup de souvenirs, nous avons un panel de témoins
que nous payons pour s'asseoir là et répondre aux
questions que les gens veulent leur poser
indirectement, bien sûr, vous savez ce que vous avez
vu, ils veulent leur demander, ils aiment ça
là-bas et nous essayons d'ajouter quelque chose
chaque année, nous  avoir une course de 5 km, nous avons un
grand concours de beauté Mothman à partir
des faux yeux bas et rouges. Ten Feet Tall
baby, ce n'est pas de chance
dans le concours du festival Mothman.
tenue
et nous obtenons des ailes parfois les candidats
ont des ailes parfois les candidats
ne veulent tout simplement pas montrer leur personnalité, donc ce
sont de vrais stylistes ne devraient pas battre euh
ils concourent également en robe de soirée et
sur scène question et ce que les juges
essaient généralement de rechercher est  juste une
fille naturelle qui veut
vraiment promouvoir le concours du Mothman Festival
et pas seulement après la couronne
et la ceinture, mais en fait pour promouvoir le
festival auquel
je suis allé en 2010,
c'était vraiment assez surprenant
parce que je n'avais jamais fait de concours auparavant
alors  J'étais vraiment nerveux et j'ai toujours
aimé le Mothman et tout
ça alors j'ai pensé hé pourquoi ne pas
essayer et puis voilà j'ai gagné ce qui
était absolument fou mais le concours euh
était en fait vraiment cool comme si nous devions
apprendre le  La danse Mothman qui était vraiment
amusante Muff Man, il n'est pas du Japon, il est une
véritable Amérique, les
étrangers viennent littéralement du monde entier
et c'est pourquoi nous l'appelons le
seul musée Mothman au monde, mais nous avons
des accessoires, nous avons des archives très rares, nous avions
beaucoup de John  Souvenirs de quille, nous transportons
des marchandises et nous avons commencé, vous savez, à
ouvrir deux ou trois jours par semaine maintenant,
nous sommes ouverts sept jours sur sept à
l'étranger
et nous sommes des gens bien informés qui veulent
entrer et nous poser des questions, nous montrons
des documentaires et des choses comme ça  J'aime
vraiment être un guide touristique Je rencontre
des gens du monde entier
c'est vraiment cool nous pouvons les emmener dans la
région UT leur permettre de tout voir jusqu'aux
différents sites de Point Pleasant Je
raconte différentes histoires qui m'ont été
racontées  au fil des années à propos du
Mothman et de toutes les différentes rencontres
avec lui, les histoires que j'ai entendues
des témoins oculaires eux-mêmes, puis nous
sortons et nous vérifions les igloos et
regardons le premier euh où la première
observation a été, c'est vraiment très
amusant j'apprécie  c'est
[Musique]
bien qu'il n'y ait jamais
vraiment eu d'observations de Mothman signalées
dans les igloos, c'est toujours une
partie fascinante de l'
histoire de la région de TNT car vous pouvez voir
les murs épais de quatre pieds de nombreux
groupes paranormaux fréquentent les igloos
parce qu'ils savent qu'ils veulent essayer d'
attraper les orbes et différentes images
et des choses comme ça donc c'est euh c'est
une partie vitale de l'histoire de Mothman et
je pense qu'il faut faire des recherches un
peu plus
[Musique]
étrangère
[  Musique]
une telle créature qu'il est difficile de ne pas la
regarder, c'est qu'il s'inspire en quelque sorte d'un
monstre du Loch Ness et de Bigfoot, mais je
pense que la nôtre est un peu plus excitante
parce qu'il, euh, il se montre juste
partout et il y a tellement d'
histoires derrière lui que  ça a changé notre
ville
[Applaudissements] l'
une des principales attractions ici au
centre-ville de Point Pleasant est la
célèbre statue de Mothman cette statue est venue
environ deux trois ans après
la sortie du film et un artiste local qui
travaille l'acier inoxydable nommé Bob roach
a créé cette statue  après s'être assis
avec certains des témoins Mothman et des témoins
oculaires et des choses comme ça et il est
venu à sa propre
version de ce Mothman, mais des gens du
monde entier viennent se faire
prendre en photo avec cette statue dans laquelle nous avons dévoilé
la statue  une cérémonie qui a attiré
les nouvelles nationales
CBS Sunday Morning est venue et cela
nous a tous choqués, nous pensions que ce ne seraient que
quelques personnes de la ville et peut-être
quelques stations locales, mais nous sommes immédiatement
passés à la télévision nationale lorsque la statue
a été dévoilée vraiment euh  belle œuvre
d'art que vous connaissez avec beaucoup de détails
et des choses comme ça, mais c'est une
belle pièce maîtresse pour faire savoir aux gens que
vous savez ce qui s'est passé ici
Mothman est une grande partie de l'histoire de
Point Pleasant il y a d'autres morceaux d'
histoire  nous avons aussi un tramway Mothman qui
circule dans la ville, vous pouvez
l'interrompre ici et cela vous mènera à
toutes nos entités que nous avons le
musée de la rivière derrière le mur anti-inondation pour les
peintures murales du Silver Bridge Memorial
tout ce que nous avons  le fort
Randolph continue mais le tram
vous emmènera pour vous montrer que nous avons plus que
Mothman, nous avons l'histoire et les
familles étrangères mystérieuses viennent de tous les groupes viennent
des visites en bus viennent les gouverneurs viennent se faire prendre en
photo avec le Mothman
c'est  pas une vraie
visite à Point Pleasant à moins que vous ne vous fassiez
prendre en photo avec le Mothman
Je ne sais pas comment l'expliquer mais
ils sont ici tous les jours à peu près toute
l'année
Je me fiche de savoir s'il pleut de la neige ou
ce qu'il y a des gens
se faire prendre en photo avec le
Mothman, c'est vraiment
phénoménal auquel
vous n'auriez jamais pensé, mais c'est
ici,
je ne peux pas dire avec certitude si c'est réel
ou non, je sais juste qu'il y a
énormément de preuves que c'est
nous invitons tout le monde  venir ici
et les emmener et leur montrer toutes les
différentes attractions qui
y sont destinées et les laisser se décider
par eux-mêmes,
le Mothman est la grande chose avec beaucoup
de gens, c'est en quelque sorte mettre Point
Pleasant sur la carte dans la plupart  ces dernières années
et les gens viennent juste parce qu'ils en ont
entendu parler et c'est un peu mystérieux
et ils veulent voir à quoi ça ressemble,
nous avons la statue en ville et donc
c'est quelque chose qui est visible pour eux,
vous savez
[Musique]
nous avons tellement  beaucoup d'histoire américaine ici, nous
avons beaucoup d'histoire agricole,
évidemment, nous avons une histoire paranormale
et nous aimons simplement avoir des visiteurs, nous
apprécions vraiment les gens qui viennent
tout le monde en ville sort et parle à
tout le monde et ils sortent sur la rue principale
et s'assoient dans le rocking  des chaises et
parler à tous les gens qui viennent, c'est
un moyen idéal pour amener les gens à venir à
Point Pleasant, puis à jeter un coup
d'œil et ils trouveront peut-être quelque chose d'autre
qu'ils ne savaient pas sur les gens que le
Mothman et ils sont  n'arrêterons jamais de
venir, nous le savons et nous apprécions tous
les différents qui viennent
étrangers
[Musique] étrangers
[Musique]